[Applause]  the Bank of pretty  for $44  [Music]  bill these pills trying to shed man's  gotta get it goes to the basket points  in the court not a high offense guy is  Luka hasn't come back saddle ranch tthe  Catana game this year but he is  averaging a bit over 13 Luka  [Music]  are a tie game of the 1/2 of the line  bike effort I step back shallots leave  us wait  [Applause]  the open court with the sighs all the  way to the real national crossover  playing the theme this shots off tonight  he now has ten rebound  goes to the cup again Kristen misses a  three you've been looking at the head  [Applause]  statistically about  they're usually glass that's a tough  shot yes may look easy I tell my reasons  for the faint buzz of your first trip  [Applause]  [Music]  all stick-to-itiveness  [Applause]